well it is no secret that robert de niro
hates President Trump today the world is
suffering from the real Donald Trump the
president the guy is a fool come on
this guy has sullied the presidency he's
debased the presidency it's it's just
it's just beyond surreal he has no idea
of what his purpose in life is as the
president should be I always say he's a
lowlife
yeah he's a lowlife but now the Raging
Bull actor is taking things to a whole
new level check out what many are
calling his most unhinged anti Trump
rant yet I'd like to see a beggar right
in his face hit him right in the face
like that and let the picture go all
over the world and that would be the
most humiliating thing because he needs
to be humiliated he needs to be
confronted and humiliated by whoever the
the the his opponent is his political
opponent Wow okay so basically we needed
to bleep out most of all of that he's
sounding a little bit to me more like
Joe Pesci than Robert De Niro and you
know here's somebody who you know from
day one has not been a fan of President
Trump but you know look my question to
you Tom Shalu yeah is when are we going
to give up on caring about what
celebrities think about politics I mean
who cares me look you know he has like
his right to we have his opinion and
everything else but I mean why are we
even talking about this well people love
this stuff they love the most strident
anti Trump voices but you notice the
people like De Niro he has a great deal
of intelligence as an actor when you
watch him work he's obviously he's super
gifted and he has intelligence in that
area but when he talks about politics
it's not smart at all
so he obviously he's got a block there
he's also very angry and why has the
president debased the presidency when De
Niro is saying worse things than Donald
Trump ever said with this I'd like to
smear a bag of you-know-what in his face
wide like why does he think that is
gonna make his point I don't really
understand so I would like to sit with
him and say look if he has debased the
presidency the country everything
so much what is it give me the line the
thing that Tom says is this an
invitation for Robert DeNiro to come on
your quiz show I love it I would love it
but yeah it is and I want to contrast
someone like DeNiro with someone like
John Boyd when he speaks about politics
he articulates policy he talks about
actual things not just I want to shove a
bag I loved him as Zoolander's father I
just want to point that out so so Emily
you know you bring up the Tom brought up
this point about Jon Voight but you know
if someone said this about Hillary
Clinton about Barack Obama but any
Democratic what about Nancy Pelosi you
know if it was an actor a more
conservative leaning saying they want to
throw certain things and and one of
these democratic elected space do you
think that we would just be brushing it
off or would we be talking about it well
I think that no matter what there is a
bias and mainstream media that would be
hypocritical in its coverage of who says
what about what side of the party or
what party um for me when I hear this I
just take it as comedy like you guys
heard me laughing like I think it's
funny to hear it that way I listen to
anyone who is thoughtful regardless of
what they are saying or what their views
are if they're thoughtful and articulate
then I listen and then I form my own
opinion I think what disturbs me more
coming out of Hollywood though is that
the celebration of being arrested and I
think that kind of the fabric the the
fragrance of it's my turn like I think
that's a disgusting shameful
trivialization of what is a crippling
aspect of our society and if they had
any type of gravitas have made any kind
of self-respect then they would take
that energy and that exposure and put it
towards actual criminal justice reform
rather than shoving in our face the fact
that very wealthy attorney can get them
out of jail immediately and I know Jenna
you've talked about that before I've
seen you post on Twitter about you know
the concerns about you know somebody
like Jane Fonda just going out there and
getting arrested time and time again and
then what kind of message does that send
to young people celebrity talks about
politics it's like when I try to talk
about sports everybody manages and no
one takes it seriously and when it comes
to Robert DeNiro so my husband and
stepson last night they started watching
the movie on Netflix
Irishman oh yeah and I was like kind of
turned I I have to separate my politics
from from the entertainment that I like
to watch but I have to say like for this
one in particular I was like yeah I'm
just like not that into it and I left
interesting Jessie what's your take on
this or are you signing up for what
Robert De Niro or selling or what no I
actually was talking to your husband
about this and we agreed he's a great
actor but he plays the same character in
every single role and now he's playing
the same character every time he does an
interview he's just a trump painter and
I think this is just publicity for the
Irishman his team knows it is Entourage
thinks it's good because usually he's a
boring interview and now he gets real
animated when he talks about how much he
hates Trump so they're going with it
also I don't think people care about
what these celebrities say about
politics anymore is because 20 years ago
they were the only ones that could get
on their soapbox and have a platform now
everyone knows Twitter everyone on
social media there's thousands of
different of cable channels everyone can
say whatever they want so what he says
doesn't have a big of his impact well
and we haven't heard I don't think we've
heard president Trump tweet about this
yet but who knows anything's possible